[Music]
we get in close you all know the drill
intercept the convoy watch out for cable
edit there's this kid he's in trouble
louvered I pump the hate breaks Thanos
Halon cable get tools but I can't do
this alone
made backup we're gonna form a super
duper [ __ ] group it's time to get
back on LinkedIn means bad luck
my name is chatter stock Domino I'm
lucky luck isn't a superpower
it's certainly not very cinematic yes it
is let's meet in the middle and say no
it is [ __ ] have it's show time
don't call it a comeback
[ __ ] clown dressed up as a sex toy
so darks you sure you're not from the DC
Universe
bring it on one night really
whoo yeah your bullets they're really
fast last but not least Peter
any powers when I tell us about you know
I don't have one
I just saw the ad you're in as a
quadriplegic must be frustrating for you
someone who liked to get things done of
their hands
is that thing for guys murdered miles I
could find these men
dude what if I told you I could offer
you something that would enable you to
walk again
I call it stem a computer chip that has
potential to change everything it's a
new better brain
I instead the system operating in body
40 we can maybe but you'll see here you
know only you may I point something out
in the drum surveillance footage serve
Brandner Marine Corps address for one
for citrus new ground we'll need a plan
I got this this doesn't seem like a plan
[Music]
stay down there we have to
you are involved in this somehow they
need to let me know well I was in the
area detectives
[Music]
spend what do you think I should do
great you are persistent
and I cannot allow us to do we were
going to finish the job we started you
didn't know that I'm a ninja why I am
state of the art I am NOT a ninja did
you wash your hands with soap did you
dry them all vegetables who ordered all
vegetable I did so are we going to talk
about it what the elephant in the room
what elephant moms new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right help me bring supers back into the
sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me I'll watch the kids no problem
not the way you're supposed to do it dad
they want us to do it I don't know that
way why would they change math NASA's
Batman hello hey honey
catch everything's great
[Music]
in track track he's in excellent health
[Music]
that is freaky you know it's crazy right
to help my family I gotta leave it to
fix the law I gotta break it you got two
more kids can have that choice thank you
young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
[Music]
the screen slider interrupts this
program for an important announced that
it might get weird I'll be there ASAP
you better be back
[Music]
she's tracked okay okay okay
how many can you save 11 species blues
the last of her kind you'll never
capture her we thought you might know
someone who could help a rescue op what
could go wrong
hey blue you know me
come with me you know you can't stay
here it was all alive
the man who proved Raptors can follow
orders you never thought how many
millions a trained predator might be
woods
there is seldom not blue they need it
for something else this is the most
dangerous creature that ever walked the
earth I say we shut this whole thing
down
hey girl you think what I'm thinking
genetic power has now been unleashed you
can't put it back in the box
if I'll make it back
remember you're the one who made me come
here I'll be all right
these creatures were here before us and
if we're not careful they're gonna be
Hereafter welcome to Jurassic world
[Music]
thank you for bringing us collectively
to this moment it is a moment but so
many have dreamed of claiming history
starts today
[Music]
the guy who is the evil person I don't
work for him my phone works Bremen are
you gonna behave yourself tomorrow
I totally don't want to my job I'm a
reporter I follow people that do not
want to be followed
what about the allegations that you
recruit the most vulnerable for tests
that end up killing people you tell me
Joe finish mr. boss is that a threat we
had to learn how to hide in plain sight
I'm pretty good at it for you
you suck whoever you are I work at the
Life Foundation and I need your help
we found something we call them
symbiosis Carleton Drake believes that
the union between human and symbiote is
the key to our evolution
I'm really sick
I'm hearing boys
you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people when I see it do whatever we
want do we have a deal
really sacrifice
the one thing you haul most dear
you should be extremely afraid
what the hell are you we
often
this is the grill for you I called it
the Obama come on say Emma's my Elmo the
Pip Boy
I call this the big black machine oh my
god do you smell gas a little bit came
out but how's the nervous
that's just equivalent you're the best
salesman I've ever seen I can see you
being a stockbroker like me could you
give me a job I wish I could my boss
won't let me hire I'll drop that burger
he dropped out of Harvard you dropped
out of Piedmont high that was a couple
credits shy of graduating I got to get
my GED I'm the principal of this school
I can do whatever I want
yo ran my house
are you using a blank voice no I don't
hear color alright let's do some
introductions my name is Carey I'm here
to make a little extra cash so that I
can afford this one that I got but
that's none of your business
welcome to night school this book is
kind of thick I thought it'd be more
like a leaflet if you're not gonna do
the work drop the class no I'm gonna do
the work you'll see we'll see
yes we will great superb excellent good
[Music]
you're gonna be a financial analyst I am
and it starts immediately I've been
waiting on the Lord to bring me a
pint-sized little man who can fill this
out let me get you check it from the
Lord
you take that test all right tenderize
your way thank you are you trying to get
your GED are you trying to get your GED
yes you can get out my way be
my suspicions were correct oh you're
clinically down there is no cure for
what you have oh my god I got learning
herpes I got to give the people give it
boy you did the black boys thing we have
it's not a black voice not a black voice
you don't remember when you was in that
meeting you was like we gonna get it lit
up in here this meeting lit it was very
lit I keep it 100 when have I ever not
kept it 100
[Music]
we have all the good men gone and where
where's a streetwise Hercules
you're looking particularly beautiful
tonight there a problem
good the identities of our serving
agents have been exposed the country is
in a state of complete chaos the
universe sends me you sir yes alright
buff we're going on a mission not a
honeymoon destination
south of France sir I'm the Mossad
they're just cyclists so they're French
cyclist buff and they're obstructing Her
Majesty's Secret Service she's the key
to this case I'm not sure I've ever met
a man quite like you let me clear up the
uncertainty here you haven't
virtual reality
it's completely immersive and some
people lose track of their actual
surroundings I think we can pretty much
guarantee that's not gonna happen tell
me the agent you've got in the field is
making some progress target acquired
this is a job for the shoe box and no
one must have a slightest clue we're
here
[Music]
till we meet again
that was sooner than I expected
first time no no no long time ago
different life now you come back yes I'm
looking for something you can find
whatever you wish
until today I'm at a man who kidnapped a
little girl from our American mother
will not be looking for such a man will
be dangerous for you men like him with
big Robert I have my only friend that's
great you're helping all these random
people and every
[Music]
but stay off the radar something happens
to one of ours so I'm obligated to look
into them about you every time oh I am
just like you're dead
[Music]
yeah it's a matter
[Music]
they knew what floor she was off
they're tying up loose ends exactly
partner for seven years max mistake to
go to war with him they're gonna war
with me
whoever did this of all chart skill sets
it with the agency family it was East I
tried very good well not one one goat
they killed my friends
so I'm gonna kill each and every one of
them and only disappointment is that I
only get to do it once
see you Karen all those books around I
figured you for some kind of teacher
from a high level become an assassin
tonight allows people a release for all
the hatred and violence if they keep up
inside the booth this won't bring him
back
it won't make you feel any better thank
you it is a night that is defining our
country
citizens this will be a tradition we
celebrate every year join the first
purge oh do you think says always see
tonight people are now calling this
controversial experiment of legalized
crime the purge you and I they just stay
with me doing approach oh we're gonna be
fine on how we are here with dr. may up
Dale she came up with this experiment is
the purge a political device it is a
psychological one if we want to save our
country we must release all our anger in
one night tonight will see the good and
evil and everyone this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the first purge our
neighborhood is under siege from a
government who doesn't give a [ __ ] about
any of us at the siren all crime
including murder will be legal for 12
hours there's a lot of good people out
there who we gonna have to protect you
all emergency services will be suspended
we gotta be prepared for anything your
government thanks you for your
participation parties you predicted a
much higher level of participation human
nature does not obey the laws of
politics what the hell is going on
they all ex-military some funky going
down D you're saving soldiers into the
island disguised as citizens this
country needs for the store no one's
coming to help us
after tonight nothing will ever be the
same again they forgot about one thing
they forgot about us what have I done
wrong
just remember all the good the purge
does
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a monster outside what you
people discovered is bigger than we ever
thought yes
how big is that thing what's the largest
shrimp that ever existed the living
fossil thoughts have been extinct over
two million years
what good
it's Megalodon he's kidding right
[Music]
[Music]
that things out there need to find it
and kill it
let's just put a tracker on it
you guys ever watch Shark Week
[Music]
he looks heroic but it's kind of got a
negative attitude
sure on this you ugly
[Music]
you